welcome to this video playing gram mass
the snow kit no no name so g3 yeah one
it often leads to transposition this
opening and this time okay I'm probably
to some English because it will play
five I guess but I like this set up the
board winning set up so let's get this
on c5 is an interesting move now nope
yeah that is actually quite nice for
white much I mean not like brilliant or
anything but I think what does enjoy
slight advantage in this position
lighten up and Bishop e3 Queen d2 King
edge to all that moves it's quite okay
what enjoys a good central control and
it's not so clear what what blacks plane
is I've played quite a bit of this of
this position sir when I was more
regularly playing 1c form so usually
quite comfortable to play white is
coming from some thought of a 3d for
later yeah i know i'm playing quickly
and i always condemn people for doing
that but this is a position type that i
had on the board tons of times so i can
play it rather quickly
that that is interesting trying for one
night to be 3m okay so night to deform i
wonder if i can go to g one that is an
idea for 93 interesting let's do it the
a for the a for porn is a bit weakish
where Knight f3
hmm now that's actually quite okie from
like it looks very okay hmm very active
okay let's do that so if i take d 4 f 2
is just hanging this is a huge issue
okay i have to do that on c6 I have
Knight b6 and pick up the porn but the
whole thing looks quite shaky m 00
interesting ok let's take with that if i
take with the e porn you might get okay
I thought g5 was an idea this is why I
went h4 trying to prevent that and a
half Bishop h3 to e6 possibly it looks
quite nice also be five surprise me
okay Bishop H 3286 that looks ok so if I
go it's not trapping the Queen so let's
cover you for first know how am i doing
that I have to be um have to be a
circumspect if I if I just play Bishop
age 36 um that's nice but it's not clear
how good it is because he can sacrifice
the exchange quite often I think that I
should yep let's do that but not put it
only six so quickly this is interesting
but I thought Bishop f5 actually might
be good I have to check on h5 got the
check down
it's true if I take on a tech g5 then go
to f5 shouldn't be bad actually is a
check on f2 whoops open not good what
about Bishop f5 it's the come on let's
play them and not waste a ton of time ah
the only way to lose this game is to
blunder a piece and I managed yes great
how ridiculous is that yeah okay the
simple move tactics you should see it
doesn't even if the opponent played
really badly before it's just it's just
a piece a piece is a piece of the piece
Wow bad bad bad bad bad okay Jim spoiled
it's very very nice position here
no every move wins Queenie three wins
are just stupid yep just a quiet reason
once London and black was already
completely completely outplayed with
with multiple things actually you can
probably do many things that are good
yeah so what what am i doing I mean I
can also play play 36 I don't know this
can probably also improve a little bit
him the problem is he has no porn break
that C point is we keep on this week
that's all really not not good and even
putting it only six the bishop is not a
bad idea ok so I went here koukash one
might even be more precise can I check
it even and then look f2 ok that's a bit
of play so what is the best way let's
see the computer wants to go here and
this this and wide wins Joe it's
possible it's a very nice sequency
actually check got this one as well
check check down here that's also coming
Jim that it was a very very nice
position I was surprised the sequence
takes and b5 is just terribly bad it
might be a gem but this is just terribly
bad I mean it just gives gives me a big
advantage while here I think black
should be fine he has many many possible
ideas one ideas to to make this night
look stupid because it cannot go back
yeah this is an interesting move for
example not taking yeah the idea is that
after he's threatening c6 you just don't
take and he I have huge trouble when
journal square so I really played it
badly up to that point but this is
completely turning the tables yeah but
this is right Ruth look here see one
maybe add some some way to improve but
that looked the computer actually gives
rook h1 probably completely getting this
out of the picture check and this for
Queen age seven yeah that's that's
actually that's really over yeah but
check and oops no Bishop to g5 yeah you
should Bishop f5 just yeah okay it
happened it happened it doesn't help
yeah even I mean he made a strategically
a terrible decision with Bishop b5 and
takes but he's not a piece down and it
doesn't help if you play this idiotic
blunder yeah it's everything else is
knowledge void after that so pretty
pretty bad loss IAM okay well thanks for
watching